nintendo seems to be working on
something very special with the NX but
they haven't released any official
information yet but thanks to a report
from Eurogamer we may be getting a
glimpse into what nintendo is cooking up
multiple sources have confirmed a few
details about the big ends next console
to the site according to the report the
NX is a powerful handheld device with
detachable controller modules that fit
on either side of its screen this device
can also be connected to a docking
station to display games on a TV screen
the whole thing will run on a
proprietary operating system not on
Android like some early reports
suggested as for games it seems Nintendo
is going back to cartridges though it's
unclear what the capacity of these new
carts would be still it sounds like the
NX will be quite the unique device
Nintendo confirmed that the NX will
release in March 2017 so we should
expect an official announcement in the
coming months whether they announced it
at a convention or give it its own
Nintendo Direct you'll hear about it
from GameSpot and for all things
Nintendo you're already in the right
place
you